Let's start by looking at line f, this turquoise line right here. I like to find
the y-intercept first, which on line f, is at 0, negative 2. So b is just
negative 2. Then I can use this point to help me find the slope. If I move over
1 to the right, I need to move down 1 in order to hit the line again. So, the
slope is going to be negative 1 over 1 or other words just negative 1. For line
g, the y-intercept is actually the origin, 0, 0. This means that b has to equal
0. To find the slope, I see that if I start at the origin, I can move to the
right 2 units and then down 1 unit to reach the graph again. So, the slope is
going to be negative 1, since we moved down 1 in the y direction, over positive
2, since we stepped 2 to the right. So, the slope is negative 1/2. And lastly,
we come to line h. This intersects the y-axis at 0, 3, b then is 3.
Interestingly enough, just like with g, if we walk over 2, we have to walk down
1 to get back to the graph. So, the slope for this is also negative 1/2.